Ok, kids, story time, I love story time.
Sixty six million years ago,
it was a perfect day.
Dinosaurs roamed the earth, tending to their
young feeding, enjoying the warmth of the
sun. Fish and sea creatures weave through tangled
algae in the deep blue waters of the
ocean. Tiny mammals burrowed in holes deep in
the ground, snug and safe from the
predators lurking above, and then in
one second the world ended.
Let's find out why. Welcome to the Y files
were smart folks like us come to laugh and
learn. Sixty six million years ago, the entire
course of history on our planet changed.
In an instant, a giant asteroid almost 20
kilometers wide, or about twice the size of
Mount Everest, smashed into the earth at
12 miles per second per second.
That's over fifty thousand or forty
times the speed of sound.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What happened?
Well, chaos happened.
Chaos that would cause mile high Surinamese across
entire oceans and walls of fire across
entire continents, chaos that would wipe out 70
percent of life on earth, chaos that
would kill the dinosaurs and chaos
that would change our planet forever.
The asteroid smashed into the Yucatan Peninsula,
resulting in a massive explosion that
created one of the largest known impact craters
on Earth at ninety three miles in
diameter. This happened just outside the little
town of modern day chick shlub Mexico.
This catastrophic event is known
as the shlub impact.
What kind of little chicks you got it.
The estimated energy of the impact was somewhere
between two and over 50 yards of jewels
is a lot of jewels, a lot of jewels.
Oh, yes. Let's keep it conservative and
say the impact was to Yatta jewels.
That's the same as 40 billion times the
energy delivered by the atomic bomb in Hiroshima,
40 billion times.
And all of that energy occurred in
less than one second all at once.
The Cretaceous period, which lasted about 80 million
years and did the very second this
asteroid hit the earth. This gave way to a
new era, an era of calamitous death and
destruction of massive craters and flaming forests
of the extinction of the dinosaurs.
This moment, the moment of the Chichibu
impact, marked the beginning of the Setas
Ogiwara. The blast was so extreme that in the
sky above it where there should have been
er, the rock had punched a
hole of outer space in vacuum.
And as the atmosphere rushed in to close
the hole, enormous volumes of Earth were
expelled into orbit and beyond all within
a second or two of impact.
Now this material which included pieces of
the asteroid itself, were set aflame and
rained back down on the earth as fiery
rock each chunk the size of a skyscraper.
The impact had other disastrous consequences.
A mega tsunami over three hundred and thirty
feet tall erupted from the sea and stretched
all the way from Mexico to Texas and Florida.
And that was lucky. Lucky the water in
the Gulf of Mexico is relatively shallow.
If the asteroid had struck in the Pacific
Ocean, it would have unleashed tsunamis five
kilometres high.
That sounds high it and it's
higher than most aircraft fly.
Oh, boy. Is it over yet?
Oh, no. It's just getting started
across land for thousands of miles.
Death was instant.
And this is shown by fossils discovered in
soil samples from New Jersey, which is thirty
one hundred miles away.
Now, while some life survive the impact,
there was an immediate mass extinction of
millions of species.
As for the dinosaurs, no one knows whether their
species died out all at once or if it
took weeks to fully eliminate them.
But either way, this was
the day the dinosaurs died.
When the asteroid hit,
it plunged deep underground.
Less than one second later, superheated dust, ash
and steam exploded from the depths of
the crater and were thrown
high into the earth's atmosphere.
And rocks at the impact site contain large
amounts of sulphur that went vaporized led to
a sulfate haze that spread across the entire surface
of the earth and led to years of
environmental conditions that would suffocate even more
life on the planet known as an
impact winter. The dust, ash and haze blocked
out the sun, creating a decade long winter
across the entire planet.
Winter is here. My father always promised
the plants just couldn't grow in these
conditions and the food chain was demolished.
It was impossible for dinosaurs to survive
if they didn't die immediately after impact.
They were definitely wiped out by
the end of the impact winter.
How does winter kill animals?
We have with us all the
time, at least once a year.
Well, this winter was different.
It lasted years and there was no sun.
It was darkness without sun.
Photosynthesis stops without photosynthesis.
Plants die without plants.
Animals die without animals.
Bigger animals die across the entire planet.
Food wasn't just scarce.
It was gone. That things get better yet.
No, they get worse.
It allowed particles and gases released by
the many, perhaps thousands of volcanic
eruptions decimated the Earth's climate.
Poisonous snow fell around
the world for years.
Seas turned acidic.
Air was barely breathable.
Plants and animals that didn't freeze suffocated or
starved the animals that died on the
day of the impact were the lucky ones.
As winter finally end, I mean,
did they kill the Nightengale?
Whatever? Yeah, eventually things get warmer.
The happy ending, at least sauna.
The volcanoes were also
releasing carbon dioxide.
So once the impact. Particles had evaporated
from the atmosphere, the CO2 remained,
creating a runaway greenhouse effect, so
the planet began to warm again.
Now surviving life forms, most likely species
that live beneath the surface, are
protected from the blast and
its aftermath by deep dens.
And they had a chance to prosper at the
end of the winter, cold blooded reptiles who
could not generate their own body heat
at a far smaller chance of survival.
This period of warming led to the creation
of new fertile habitats across the globe, and
any life that had survived so far thrived.
Once again, this new version of the Earth
looked completely different from the days of the
dinosaurs. Predatory birds and reptiles no
longer dominated the food chain.
Mammals were prospering.
The version of the earth that
we know today had finally begun.
The chick shlub impact, which has been
theorized for decades, was only recently discovered
in 1978, geophysicist Glenn Pinfield and Antonio
Camargo were working for the Mexican oil
company Pemex as part of an airborne magnetic
survey of the Gulf of Mexico scouting
possible locations for oil drilling.
Their data showed a large concentric set of
onshore gravity anomalies looked an awful lot
like an impact crater. About the same
time, Nobel Prize winning geologist Luis Alvarez
and his son Walter were studying chemicals in
the soil when they discovered large amounts
of iridium dating back to
sixty five million years ago.
That's what Captain America Shield is made.
That's vibranium. Iridium is an element that's rare
on Earth, but it's commonly found in
meteors, superheros, a commonly
found in meteorites.
OK, OK, you're excited about MCU Phase
four, but let's let's stay focused.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Go ahead. It was then that Luis Alvarez
theorized that a massive asteroid might have hit
the earth at the beginning of the Cenizo era.
The same iridium was found in soil all around
the globe, and it contained large amounts of
soot, which would indicate forest fires across
the planet during the same time.
Also, grains of quartz were found within the
soil that had been deformed by high
shockwaves, common during explosions.
Now, in 1990, scientists finally confirmed the
massive crater now buried under deep layers
of limestone. They did this by drilling and
mapping gravity fields over the Gulf of
Mexico. Still, there's no complete
certainty about dinosaur extinction.
Nobody knows if they were killed in an instant or
in a month or over the course of years.
Most of them probably died
during the impact winter.
It's crazy to think that a nice day can
turn catastrophic in an instant, but it can.
One geophysicist said it would have been a
pleasant day one second and the world was
already over by the next.
Now the worst disaster movie
Hollywood could ever create.
Shrek would not even come close to
the destruction, the nightmare, the absolute horror
that was unleashed that day
literally out of the blue.
If there's a lesson to
be learned, it's late today.
Like tomorrow is going to suck.
Amen, brother. Our existence is fragile.
There are millions of asteroids in the solar
system and they range in size from small
pebbles up to 600 miles across
much larger than the Shlub asteroid.
In fact, there are almost two million asteroids
in our solar system that are one
kilometer wide or larger.
And many asteroid orbits intersect with the
Earth's meteor showers like the Leonids and
the Perseids and others occur when the
Earth flies through debris fields in space
weather. So you're saying
this could happen again?
There's no doubt about it.
There have been other mass extinctions
that remain mysteries to this day.
About two hundred and fifty million years ago,
it's believed that around 90 percent of
species were eliminated during a
period called the Great Dying.
Meteors impact the Earth every day, and they've
been doing so since the beginning of
time. So it's not a question of if another
large impact is going to occur on Earth.
It's just a question of when NASA tracks
the orbits of thousands of celestial objects.
There's been some pretty close calls over the years,
and I don't mean 40 years ago or 60.
I mean last July, asteroid 20, 19,
OK, missed the Earth by 45000 miles.
That's much closer to us than the moon.
And this thing was moving
at almost 90000 KPA.
Now, even though it was relatively small, it had
the energy of 30 times the atomic blast
that Hiroshima. It was called a city killer.
In August of twenty twenty, an asteroid the size
of a truck passed only 800 hundred miles
above the Indian Ocean.
That's closer to us than
a lot of orbiting satellites.
That's a close shave.
It was. There are some scientists, many
scientists who believe that the greatest threat
to our civilization is not war or plague
or climate change, but another meteor impact.
And fortunately, we had the technology to
venture to asteroids and potentially even
change their trajectory.
We will get this job done.
Your gone, but these projects are expensive
and spectacular impacts are so rare that
there's not a lot of support for this
type of initiative, but there probably should be.
Now, if we could take a break from fighting
with each other for just a minute and turn
our eyes skyward, we might see that every human
being, every form of life on this planet
has a common enemy.
And it's just a matter of
time before that enemy comes knocking.
Thanks for hanging out with us today.
My name is A.J. That's Hellfish.
This has been the wave files
we covered a lot today.
They got me thinking about potential new videos and
let me know in the comments if you'd
like to learn about how we visit asteroids, the
potential for mining them and how we can
avoid the type of impact that
threatens all life on the planet.
We're working hard for you to do us
a favor, give us a thumbs up.
And if we haven't earned your subscription today,
I promise we'll keep making fun, brainy
content until we do earn it.
Until next time, be safe, be kind
and know that you are appreciated.